hey guys welcome back to bone shaker
this video is one of the more
interesting videos of the series I think
basically because quite a lot of like
new things get done but things that I've
more or less been planning since the
beginning of the coaster like adding
more path elements redoing this station
a bit to fit in more with the rest of
the coaster and starting work on a Main
Street which have always planned to have
in front of the coaster station now I
wanted to take a bit of time to talk
about the path elements specifically as
you can see me placing these benches
around and this is a tip of which
probably many people have already more
or less realized but something I wanted
to say nevertheless and I've gotten
quite a few questions about this
basically you can see me using the 3d
gizmo all the time and it's something
that I want to do because I want to make
sure that every single object if it's
like a scenery kind of object that I
want spread throughout the park but that
you can't have to make yourself like
these lanterns or these benches it just
works so much better to make sure that
every single part of that object is part
of one building so you can just kind of
copy it around and move it as if it were
a building as I'm doing with these
lanterns over here and you can only
really do that by making the scenery out
of the by using the 3d gizmo which is
why I want to use that all the time and
after you pretty much have done that you
can just copy that Lantern or bench over
throughout the park and sort of you kind
of just have to make the object once and
then you have a new scenery item that
you can just use in whatever way your
theming you really want to do and the
other thing which I wanted to do is redo
this station just because it looked like
it didn't really fit in as much with the
rest of the ride there were like a
couple of really small things that I
wanted to do about it it's more tweaking
than really changing anything about the
station like the general shape is gonna
stay the same I just wanted to have some
slightly different colors and details
here and there because the rest of the
ride has a lot of brassy sort of dark
colors at this point but the station was
still very much white which I did
because well it's made out of details
that don't really have any other colors
but I figured it would be a nice
opportunity to try and sort of recolor
those things by placing things over them
with some slightly different colors with
the more Carosi brownie
dark collars that would fit in with the
rest of the ride a bit more and also
look a bit odd stuff like windows I
might get back a trick following this
arch I gave up on that because I wasn't
feeling like making that half circle but
I might just return to that in the
future I also wanted to do the top parts
a little bit again because it had that
sort of Disney looking wooden texture on
it and I rather want to have something
that is a bit darker a bit more detailed
more interesting to look at and some
slightly less well very bright and large
windows just some more light or small
windows I should say that our sunken
into the wall like that and kind of want
to do this same with your windows over
there and also I wanted to redo this
roof for a couple of reasons actually
and I might want to look at the rest of
the roofs as well because you might
notice that the middle roof of the
station disappears if you zoom out which
which is not really noticeable on the
time lapses because it's really fast but
basically the issue is that the brick
piece which I made it with which is like
that Battlement piece for the sandstone
castle like it's LOD is made in such a
way that some size of the brick are
still visible you zoom out but other
sites disappear so if you happen to make
walls or roofs out of the sides that
there's a peer-reviewed zoom out your
building or roof just disappears if you
zoom out too much and that's kind of an
annoying thing so just I guess a casual
warning when you're using that piece
don't be me and don't rotate the wrong
side to make your wall or roof because
I'm gonna have to look at that again at
some point in the future and yeah that
is pretty much Steve station I wanted to
do something with a pipe over here
because I still had that bit of grass
there and I wanted to have something
industrial and I figured it would be
kind of cool to have like a little gate
with one of these things where they use
that sort of supports to get a pipe to
go over the path and what I also wanted
to do and this is something that I only
recently discovered and I was really
surprised that it's actually possible
but you can have foliage within a
building so you can connect trees for
instance to a building just make it feel
on of trees and copy that all over the
place to its
they get many trees or you can make
planters out of them just have the
planters and the plant that comes in the
planter as one building that you can
just copy around and stuff like that
which I never realized before but
actually turn out to be very handy in
this case so just decorating me place a
little bit with some planters to make it
look a little bit nicer and over here I
just wanted to have something really
simple it's nothing big just I figured
it would be nice to get a little factory
like touch in here and have a small
chimney because it's something that is
of course like having the brick chimneys
is very reminiscent of like well the
steampunk theme in general I just wanted
to make sure that the chimney would be
quite small so it wouldn't really block
the view of the weenie in the background
or I should just say the main hair off
the coaster and I kind of wanted to be
small as well because otherwise it would
like draw a lot of attention toward
itself and there's already a lot of
stuff over here to look at and I'd
rather not have like this station and
the hill which the coaster is going
through and the chimney as sort of three
main high points that also draw
attention so I just wanted to have like
a sort of small low profile chimney over
there and just a bit more decoration in
a sort of industrial style over here
because I figured I can really do much
else with that little space there but I
don't think I'll do much other air
scenery around that area just to keep it
a little bit more empty now over here is
when I started work on the Main Street
and this is probably gonna require a bit
of explaining as to what style I really
want to go for because truth be told
when I started this series I said that I
would go for a Victorian sort of
architectural style and while it's
definitely seen as sort of like a
separate period in time with a very
distinct like style of buildings to it
the most I think at least the most
defining thing of Victorian architecture
is that it sort of it really goes back
to all the times it's not the sort of
postmodern and modern architecture of
the 20th century it's just taking all
the architecture and putting much more
detail in it all sorts of new deck
relations that are possible with new
materials and machines and stuff like
that so yeah that's the general idea and
I didn't really want to go for a very
specific style within that like Second
Empire Queen and for example which both
of those are actually very much found in
Disneyland's Main Street I just kind of
wanted to have a look well a bit of
freedom and just mixed up up a bit
because truth be told the architectural
styles in the Victorian period in
general also quite a bit of a mishmash
of different elements in different parts
of history all thrown together into what
was well looking good sometimes and
that's more or less or so why I didn't
really restrict myself to any given
style or remaking any sort of building
in general just kind of looking at
streets in London and especially some
streets and leads actually just taking
some inspiration from that and well just
have some fantasies about how stuff with
look so this is by no means really
supposed to be a realistic
representation of a street in England or
something like that just a bit of fun
with making some slightly big Victorian
industrial looking buildings though I
have to say I did take a lot of
inspiration specifically from the
Victoria quarter in Leeds which is
actually really nice and has a lot of
like these nineteenth-century details
but close as well and it was actually
somewhat easy since I just pretty much
had to make this one part and copy that
over with which is something that I'll
try and do for the other buildings as
well just for the sakes of well saving
time on this but as you can see it was
pretty much also necessary since I
wanted to have a lot of details in here
to kind of make these pieces of the game
itself
well unrecognizable almost in the
buildings so that's also why I wanted to
mix a lot of stuff together not really
to mix them together but sort of make
new pieces in ways that you don't really
see them in the pre given pieces in the
game which are obviously pirate themed
and don't really work out that well for
the sort of steampunk theme that I'm
going for here
and it is gonna be a pretty simple
building what I wanted to do as a
general setup of the main street is just
to make it sort of symmetrical not make
both sides exactly the same but make
them have sort of the same shape so it's
gonna be just the standard sort of
streets with towers on both sides where
you gonna look slightly different but
they're gonna have the overall sort of
same general look to them and have a
nice little spire at the end of it and
maybe some chimneys and the roofs and
things like that
it's basically what I'm looking for and
since I want to go for like sort of
rough industrial and truth be told
also a bit English kind of style to them
I wanted to just use the brick walls
mostly and use other textures for the
detailing and use the pillars to go to
get those sort of iron decorations
underneath the buildings kind of would
have loved to actually see some like
Victorian arches with awesome details
and decorations all over them which is
pretty much something I can't do
especially with the ironwork so it's
more or less trying to make it look as
if it were like one of these Victorian
decorated buildings but yeah that's the
general idea and the general so to think
that I'm trying to approach with this
building in general and especially since
it's just such a sort of flats Street
building just a town building in general
I did want to like have the details to
make it look a bit more interesting
since I can't really rely on very
interesting building shapes or anything
like that I would have actually liked to
get in bay windows because they're like
quite a well typical sort of thing that
you see in this type of architecture but
it's just something which I tried and it
was so painful to make that I figured
nope I'm gonna try to avoid that as much
as I can I'll get a few in and some
things that kind of stick I would like
bay windows but it's not something I'd
really want to go for you might also
notice that I just replaced the top of
the roof with planks which looks a bit
odd especially compared with the this
sort of brick look of these sandstone
parts but that was pretty much what I
explained in the video earlier the sort
of top gray parts which I love to use
for the roof and figured had a really
nice texture to use for this kind of
thing turns out that that's one of the
parts of the
this object that disappears if you zoom
out too much so I can kind of recommend
not using it and just going for the
planks from the scenery instead even
though they are pretty high poly and
they might start to lag your game a
little if you place too many of this
kind of roof and it's also kind of
annoying to stack all the blanks
together I'm actually quite happy with
how it looks it's almost at least if you
look from far away and kind of squint
your eyes it's almost as if it's like
this one of these metal plated roofs
anyway I also wanted to have a clock
over here and the first try was just
kind of round and kind of looked like a
clock but I wasn't really happy with how
that turned out and so I wanted to go
for something which is a little bit more
time-consuming and hard to do and try to
make and at least as perfect as I can
circle by putting all of these very
small pieces together to make the rim
around the clock which was definitely
the hardest part the inside of the clock
is pretty simple and well the white
background of it is just a fountain I
guess the only bad part about this is
that I've tried to look for like a
number of different objects using which
you can make like the details on the
clock itself but the bell just turned
out to be the best sort of thing there
is but now there is just a ton of bells
inside this building and that's also not
the best kind of thing to have if you're
looking at performance especially given
that I just simply wanted to copy this
clock over to the other side to have it
over there as well but I just wanted to
have a clock there a pretty sort of
standard thing in steampunk as well
almost as recognizable as gears and
often also we've seen in combination
with gears so I just wanted to try to
make a clock and give it a place
somewhere and since I figured the
station building itself wouldn't really
work out that well it would be nice to
just have a clock tower over here on the
side of this building and I the only
thing that I guess I did want to do with
this building is to have the clock
towers stick out a bit from the rest as
well as you might notice all of the
different parts of this building are
actually different buildings in fact
it's because I just have to copy over
entire parts but it does allow to have
like some very slight
offsets which make it kind of look a bit
more of grid and interesting to look at
so you can set this clock tower just a
couple of inches away from the rest of
the building which doesn't make a huge
build a huge difference but it still
makes the building in general a bit more
dynamic than just being one big square
with details on it which I usually try
to avoid as much as I can and on the
side of this I just wanted to have one
small building the Main Street is not
going to be too big so this will already
be the last building of the Main Street
on this side I wouldn't even really call
it a Main Street it's just sort of it's
a sort of a small themed area with which
you come into the park because this is
supposedly like one part of a different
Park and this street sort of makes the
transition from the rest of the park
into the steampunk area and sort of
really properly introduces you into the
area and so it is kind of more or less
it does the kind of job that you would
sometimes see in Disney parks for
example where you have the buildings on
one side and you go underneath them and
end up in a different area that's the
sort of idea that I was going for here
and then there's also the part on the
side just to be able to connect that to
some other part of the park which
doesn't exist since it's just one part
of the park here but I just wanted to
have that connection to at least make it
look as though this Boneshaker ride
could actually fit as a separate area
within a completely different park now
as for this little house itself it's
nothing too interesting I just figured I
kind of wanted to go for one of these
Victorian looking buildings from Notting
Hill which have these funny little
entrance ways where there is balcony
that sticks out with some pillars and
arches in front of the building and
that's the general idea I wanted to go
for here but aside from that it's just a
simple two-story townhouse it's a little
bit lower than the real-life
counterparts as well which the same goes
for the townhouse building or I should
say the building on the left of this one
just because I wanted to keep these
buildings a bit smaller since the main
street or
I keep calling a Main Street well since
this area is pretty small anyway and
there won't be too many buildings it
would just look a bit odd if the
buildings that were that were really
high since this is also supposed to sort
of form the transition from the
Steampunk area into whatever else
follows so it needs to blend in a bit
with the foliage and not stick out too
much I should say though that I didn't
really care that much for this building
enough to at least give it a fancy
little dormer and some other parts of
the roof that kind of stick out and have
some details on it but this is more or
less just a little side building to make
the shape of the street as a whole kind
of well the way I wanted it to but aside
from that I definitely want it like most
of the detail to be on the buildings
which are most prominent which is on
this side of this little street the
building with the clock tower in it and
especially the clock tower itself and on
the other side it's gonna be pretty much
the partner of the building with the
clock tower which is gonna be a slightly
different building with a slightly
different tower with a slightly
different spire on top of it which
you'll need Lee sort of run off the
leave all the introduction into this
area and that's basically that so this
is basically just a simple brick house
with a bunch of random details that I
felt like slapping onto it to at least
give it a bit of a nicer touch but aside
from that I'm not really sure what this
building is actually all about it's more
or less just filler which many main
streets are more or less used well main
centres of attention with some filler
around it though I still wanted to give
a bit of love to the filler as well
obviously and actually try a bit to get
these fires in something I've I still
kind of feel bad about a little bit or I
don't really feel bad about but I kind
of wish there was is like some really
small pieces using which you can make
like the tops of spires like some really
small decorations would you like just a
very minor point of buildings but
especially with Victorian buildings you
often have like these very small points
of spiders or these very small little
details on pillars
and it's up like that which is really
hard to get in here and which is pretty
important to get like an atmosphere or
an idea of a theme going beyond just the
general look or shape of a building so
it's that kind of thing which I was
missing here also some proper iron
fences for the balconies like it's
either the really bulky sort of
framework which is obviously not really
a proper fence or it's the really small
metal fence from the window balcony
which is used so it's more you barely
notice it so it's something I also
prefer to not use unless it's for aspire
it works pretty well for that and on
this building anyway yeah moving on on
this building I wanted to have a Dutch
gable just because that's something I
figured is actually pretty common in
this kind of building and this is also
going to be near the gates I had a
little gate plant or little it's a
pretty big gate actually I had a gate
planned just to get in through the area
which is a nice way to get more
framework and steel and steampunk
industrial kind of feeling to this area
and also have a like a nice entranceway
I do pass underneath some sort of arch
and then you feel like you're properly
in the new area so this building is just
gonna sit right next to that gate and be
very miserable and small compared to it
and so this building is also very filler
and it's pretty simple in its approach
as well just a Dutch Dutch gable with a
couple of windows though a small tip
that I could give with this is that I
didn't want to get like a couple of
wooden posts and balconies in there
which you might have seen me sink into
the building which just kind of helped
to bring out the details a little bit
more since the parts are used for the
details like the roof morning which is
this very great ish concrete they have a
really similar color because the walls
which I placed the roof morning on are
just this sort of beige ish what do they
call it again well that beige ishwor
anyway and there's barely any color
difference between that so I did want to
have some posts in there to at least
bring up the details a little bit more
but aside from that it's a pretty simple
building
and in my dreams I kind of saw this gate
as one of those arches out of iron and a
lot of interesting ornaments and
decorations all over it and things like
that but this isn't my dreams and there
is no way I could really make that and I
figured the next best thing would be to
try and get the few elements that I do
have upside down and sideways from the
poke from alpha 2.0 I think in here just
to make the sort of general shape of
what I was looking for and at some point
in the future I'll try to make a
Boneshaker sign and put that on that
thing somehow out of some elements I'm
pretty sure it should be possible to
make like some small letters I'll give
some pieces especially this little beige
wooden piece that's not something I'm
probably gonna end up doing in the
future I also wanted to have some
planters and this is something which
actually sold the Main Street actually
made quite a big difference since it's
such a sort of gloomy set of buildings
here with really dark colors and it's
really gritty and I didn't want to
breathe a bit of life into it and have
it look a little bit more brights so I
wanted to have a few flowers in the four
moon hanging baskets where you don't
really see the baskets anymore but
that's pretty common and also have some
planters along side the street now this
is what it looks like from over here
where you really see the two towers in
the distance has the big sort of thing
that you're drawn toward with the
chimney and the entrance in the front
which really gives you like them the
foreground to the background and here is
the look of the tower in the end or
nearly the end there are a couple of
things that I might change about it in
the future but this is more or less it
so yeah thank you guys for watching I'm
in the next episode and I'll try to make
the other side of the Main Street and
goodbye